[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation en
association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Sania sethova
secrétaire général de l'onde à Vélizy
bonjour bonjour alors le nom de pardon
est une salle de spectacle située à
Vélizy vous proposez tout au long de
l'année des spectacles des expositions
ou encore des rencontres quels sont les
objectifs en termes de culture de votre
salle de spectacle alors l'objectif
c'est à la fois de s'adresser au plus
grand nombre et de montrer une
excellente artistique au signe diversité
aussi bien dans les disciplines choisies
dans les propositions
dans les esthétiques dans les artistes
on accompagne à la fois de jeunes
artistes mais aussi on a des têtes
d'affiches
on a la chance d'être une scène
conventionnée d'intérêt national pour la
danse et aussi d'avoir un centre
d'ardent nos murs donc c'est vrai que le
projet est très ancré dans ces deux
disciplines là la danse et les arts
plastiques
chacune dans sa singularité mais aussi
dans tous les passerelles qui peuvent
exister entre les deux donc on est
beaucoup dans la transdisciplinarité
également et qu'est-ce que ça signifie
accompagner vous avez dit on accompagne
des jeunes artistes qu'est-ce que ça
qu'est-ce que ça signifie on a un
artiste en résidence tous les deux ans
donc là en l'occurrence c'est
wendyu qui est une chorégraphe danseuse
dont on a accompagne les spectacles on
les accueille on l'a fait aussi en
résidence on fait de la coproduction on
accompagne dans sa carrière pendant deux
ans et de temps en temps on fait des
d'accueil d'autres compagnies dans nos
salles pour pour des étapes de création
il est important selon vous de faire
rayonner la culture et proposer
justement une programmation éclectique
au spectateur oui absolument parce qu'on
s'adresse à un bassin de population qui
est très large on reste un tas de ville
mais qui rayonne beaucoup sur tout le
territoire de des Yvelines jusqu'à Paris
donc l'idée c'est que chacun puisse s'y
trouver des propositions à son goût on
va parler ensemble de la programmation
justement du mois de mai et juin deux
mois avant la fin de la saison de de
Londres mais aussi pour de nombreuses
salles des Yvelines et en France ça n'a
comment peut-on résumer la programmation
des deux derniers mois
intergénérationnel je dirais parce qu'on
a quelques propositions familiales qui
s'adressent à toute la famille à partir
de 5 ans et aussi un grand événement
pour les 20 ans de Londres c'est le
troisième et dernier rendement de cette
année pour fêter cet anniversaire le 10
juin et là on a sur un proposition
vraiment tout public qui s'adresse à
tout le monde on va parler justement
plus en détails de la programmation va
commencer avec Katia Guerrero en concert
à Londres le 11 mai qui est Katia
Guerrero
c'est une chanteuse de fado
qui a le vent en bout depuis quelques
années et qui est très qui est souvent
comparé à Amalia Rodriguez dans sa
sensibilité
le fado pour pour un petit rappel c'est
un champ populaire de du Portugal né à
Lisbonne dans le 19e siècle et c'est un
mélange enfin ça ça aînait à partir de
la rencontre entre des chants marins et
des champs de rue venus du Brésil donc
c'est un champ qui est très puissant qui
est très mélancolique
très chargée en émotions qui chantent la
solitude de l'âme les grands émotions
d'amour donc c'est sa première très très
bon moment d'émotion et pour se donner
une idée on va écouter justement un
extrait on poursuit juste après
[Musique]
nous te voilà
qui sera qui sera découvrir à Londres le
16 mai vous proposer du théâtre avec le
spectacle les règles du jeu qu'est-ce
qui attend le public pour pour cette
soirée quels sont les thématiques
abordées c'est un spectacle de théâtre
pour les enfants à partir de 8 ans et
c'est une proposition qui aborde le
thème de la guerre à travers le regard
d'enfant donc c'est l'histoire de deux
enfants nada et oldo qui se retrouvent
tous les jours à la même heure dans les
ruines de leurs écoles de leur école
pour jouer mais aussi se poser de
questions qu'est-ce qu'on fait quand
tout est perdu après les après la guerre
est-ce qu'on reste et ce qu'on serait
des choses est-ce qu'on part mais ce qui
est très bon dans le spectacle c'est
grâce à leur imaginaire ils vont
reconstruire tout un monde et le règne
de sa gazon est une artiste qui qui
s'est vraiment prendre des thématiques
qui sont qui peuvent être un peu lourds
et en faire quelque chose de très très
lumineux de très très beau avec beaucoup
d'espoir et pourquoi les règles du jeu
est un spectacle à ne pas manquer selon
vous
justement parce que ça aborde des
thématiques qui qui je trouve c'est très
important de d'en parler avec des
enfants parce qu'ils confrontés de toute
manière ils ont en parler tout le temps
que ça soit la radio à la télé sur les
réseaux sociaux et souvent ils sont
confrontés un peu sans filtre et là ça
propose une lecture qui est enfin déjà
le regard artistique permet une espèce
de distance et ça ouvre un espace de
dialogue donc on peut en parler dans un
cadre qui est sécurisant qui est qui
avec de la distance et moi je découvre
le spectacle en séance scolaire dans un
autre lieu et les gamins avaient des des
questions très très pertinentes à la
fois l'échange était très très riche
avec la compagnie donc je trouve c'est
important d'avoir ces moments là et le
24 mai le spectacle à poil accessible à
partir de 5 ans que va raconter la pièce
alors là j'ai un spectacle un peu
atypique c'est plus une expérience à
vivre qu'un spectacle au sens classique
du terme on est assis en salle parce que
justement on n'est pas si en salle on
rentre et dès qu'on rentre c'est un
plateau vide il y a juste trois armoires
sur roulettes ce qu'on appelle des fly
caisses et qui commence à bouger et en
sorte trois personnages un peu décalé un
peu mystérieux on comprend très vite
qu'il s'agit de trois techniciens de
théâtre qui tentent déchiffrer une fiche
technique et qui vont embarquer tout le
public dans la construction d'un décor
et le montage d'un spectacle donc c'est
à la fois très pédagogique et ludique et
la metteur en scène Alice la loi elle
est également marionnettiste
plasticienne donc elle a un univers
visuel qui est très qui est très poilu
je vous en dis pas plus on va écouter un
extrait pas du pas du spectacle mais du
teaser pour nous mettre un petit peu
dans l'ambiance
[Musique]
embarquer
c'est parti on traverse
[Musique]
à poil donc le 24 mai à Londres est des
séances scolaires seront prévues entre
le 22 et le 26 mai on passe maintenant
au mois de juin le 10 juin vous proposez
une performance avec le spectacle body's
in urban space qu'est-ce que ça signifie
qu'est-ce que signifie déjà une
performance et qu'est-ce qui nous attend
pour cette soirée
l'appareil c'est une vraie expérience à
vivre on a invité le chorégraphe
autrichien Willy durner pour faire ce
spectacle sur mesure c'est une
déambulation dans l'espace public qui
est créé sur mesure parce qu'il
imbriquent des corps humains qui sont
vêtus de survêtement colorés ils
imbriquent dans l'architecture urbaine
donc il se sert vraiment de la ville qui
devient un décor ce qui fait que les
spectacles sont à chaque fois très
uniques et voilà si vous vous dites on
peut voir ça ailleurs non on est les
seuls faire en France cette année
c'était vraiment une invitation pour les
20 ans parce que on voulait fêter ça
avec tout le monde et proposer quelque
chose de gratuit et qui poétise vraiment
l'espace public donc c'est on vient de
faire le casting là le 18 juin ça y est
on a nos vins performeurs et le
spectacle sera créé pendant une semaine
avant la semaine du 5 juin et il y aura
deux représentations à 11 et à 18h donc
pour bien comprendre les spectateurs
déambuleront avec Willy Dorner dans les
rues de Vélizy il y a 20 performeurs
qu'on va retrouver dans des positions
improbables dans la ville et ensuite ce
parcours là qui qui change carrément
notre regard sur l'espace public donc
une représentation à 11h une autre à 18h
combien de temps dure justement une
représentation une petite heure après ça
dépend aussi du groupe parce que plus le
groupe est grand voilà plus déplacements
sont un peu longs mais voilà il y a à
peu près 20 spots 20 arrêts tout au long
du parcours on va pouvoir retrouver les
performeurs et le même jour vous
proposez un ciné-concert quelle est la
thématique de ce ciné concert
on s'est dit qu'on voulait faire la fête
jusqu'a
u beurre
on sait à la deuxième pourquoi pas
organiser un ciné concert sur le parvis
de Londres puisque c'est ça sera le
point le point d'arrivée de la
déambulation et on a choisi Frankenstein
qui est un classique du cinéma et on a
passé commande à Joachim laterger pour
les musiques c'est un artiste aussi
qu'on aime beaucoup à Londres qu'on
accompagne souvent voilà donc ça sera
l'occasion de de faire un pique-nique en
plein air et profiter de toute la
classique
mais jusqu'au 1er juillet les citoyens
peuvent découvrir l'exposition les
vagues donc à Londres avait les immersi
beaucoup Sanya setova d'avoir été avec
nous sur sensation je rappelle que vous
êtes la secrétaire général de Londres à
Vélizy pour plus d'informations on peut
se rendre sur le site l'onde.fr et pour
revoir ou réécouter cette émission
rendez-vous sur notre site et notre
application radio sensation
[Musique]